heute meine damen und herren geht es bei
uns um die ganz großen gefühle
zu gast ist die niederländerin corry
palmen und sie ist für viele so etwas
wie eine expertin für leidenschaft um
liebe und für die abgrundtiefe
verzweiflung denn schon zwei mal hat sie
einen liebespartner und den tod verloren
und das leben wie das sterben so
herzzerreißend in ihren besten mann
beschrieben dass ich selber die lektüre
zeitweise kaum er trug und mich fragte
wie ist das eigentlich mit der liebe
die conny kolmann als eine urgewalt
bezeichnet ist die glück oder gefährdung
denn eines ist klar in ihren büchern
geht es heftig zu und her
conny palmen ein beispiel für so eine
heftige liebe ist in em da begegnen sich
zwei liebende die haben sich erst gerade
seit ein paar tagen überhaupt
kennengelernt
sie begegnen sich sie pinkelt sich in
die hose er sagt er hätte sich in die
hose gekocht ist das eigentlich
metaphorisch gemeint
ja und nein es ist wirklich passiert
aber was man in einen roman tut oder in
einem buch literarisches buch ist es
eine extra bedeutung geben und das hat
alles setzen mit der sehr schöne
ladinische sekret sekretion also
abscheidung und das heißt auch zu
gleicher zeit dass das die zwei angst
haben aber auch sich vorgenommen haben
keine geheimnisse kurz zu haben und ist
ein solcher moment dann auch peinlich
weil sich in die hose machen ich kenne
so was wenn man wahnsinnig lachen ist ja
wohl weniger aber zur gleichen zeit war
es auch so haben wir so gelacht und esra
war auch warte schon jahrelange
psychoanalyse also wir haben auch uns
gegenüber darüber gesprochen was
bedeutet das freud war unser guter
freund an diesem
aber wir haben zugleich auch sehr
gelassen ich mache jetzt zähle war
sozusagen transparent was in dem buch
auch klar es ist ihre eigene geschichte
ist eine geschichte zwischen ihnen und
dem talkmaster ist ja ja wenn man das
buch liest und überhaupt ihre bücher
liest ich habe schon angetönt dann kommt
diese urgewalt der liebe ganz stark zum
zug man hat das gefühl ihre liebenden
und sie selber lieben extrem
leidenschaftlich man hat die
körperfunktionen nicht mehr im griff man
verzehrt sich nacheinander die frauen
winseln vor sehnsucht sie beißen sich
statt was sie sich küssen
woher kommt diese urgewalt ich denke
sagt mit persönlichkeit zu tun mit einer
leidenschaftlichen persönlichkeit und
mit eine ängstliche persönlichkeit eine
nervöse persönlichkeit das sind die
typische personen die sich auf diese art
liebe wie ich sie oft beschreiben also
symbiotisch ängstlich mit sehr viel
bindungs und verlass uns angst mit
eigentlich keine mühe mit intimität ein
großes verlangen nach intimität große
sucht mentalität zu gleicher zeit auch
angst dafür weil das verlangen so groß
ist
also wenn jetzt team und sagte ich liebe
ganz anders ich bin eher der typ für das
taube herzklopfen händchenhalten erste
küsse und dann irgendwann ein geregeltes
sexleben dann würden sie sagen das ist
nicht unbedingt ein anderer typus von
liebe sondern es waren eine andere typ
von persönlichkeit italia bestimmt ihr
lieb ist gut die liebe liebe ist liebe
nein das ist eine ganz andere
persönlichkeit stimmt und auch eine
persönlichkeit mit ganz andere wünsche
ich meine wenn man zb sich nach kinder
sind und nach ein leben das sehr
vorstellbar ist dann wird man nicht sich
die männer aussuchen die ich mir
ausgesucht habe sie haben selber ja
keine kinder wollten ganz bewusst keine
kinder
ja ich wollte keine kinder denn ich hab
gewusst und das gehört auch zu diesem
modernen charakter
ich habe gewusst dass ich das nicht
kombinieren konnte mit schreiben wenn
ich an einem buch arbeitet und auch wenn
ich nicht an ein buch arbeit ist nämlich
einen buchen dann ist ein buch immer in
meinem kopf
und wenn ich mich verantwortlich fühlen
für kinder sind die kinder immer in
meinem kopf
ich war also typische über besorgte
neurotische mutter sein und jetzt bin
ich eine über besorgte neurotische
schriftstellerin aber sie sind doch auch
eine entschuldigung über besagte
neurotische liebhaberin auch ja das hat
ein mann hat platz aber ein kind nicht
ja aber ein mann erträgt dass man hat
damit einen erwachsenen zu tun der mich
wahrscheinlich ziemlich ähnlich säten
neurotische menschenleben eigentlichen
russische menschen oder wie ich es
eigentlich in log buch beschreibe ist es
dass man nicht einen anderen liebt das
wohin er stark ist oder talent voll oder
bequem
man spürt eigentlich clark und die liebe
man liebt eigentlich die schwache eines
anderes in den mund die ängste die das
wo er nicht gut ist
sie erwähnen das logbuch eines
unbarmherzigen jahres das ist das buch
dass ihre zweite ganz ganz große liebe
beschreibt zu hans van mierlo einem
niederländischen politiker beide männer
sowohl ich habe ja wie auch hans van
mierlo sind gestorben
darüber werden wir später noch sprechen
bleiben wir noch kurz bei dieser
symbiotischen lieben interessiert mich
sehr
sie selber erwähnen in diesem logbuch
den den mythos des kugl menschen von
platon mehr
das ist also eine geschichte die die
symbiotische liebe sehr sehr stark macht
die geschichte das zeugs die menschen
gespalten hat es waren kugel menschen
mann und mahnen frauen frau oder mann
und frau die rollen durch die welt die
menschen haben aufbegehrt sie waren
weil ich zu den göttern und zeus hat sie
gespalten dann nicht mehr so auf mächtig
sind und seither so der mythos suchen
die menschen ihre bessere hälfte die
hälfte ich zu ihm passt und man sucht
eigentlich nach dieser symbiose wieder
ist ein bild mit dem sie viel anfangen
kann
ja das ist ein bild das ich sehr gut
verstehen dass mich immer gerührt hat
und das wird klar machte dass ich so ein
jemand bin der sich sehen nach das
aufheben auch es ist das hat auch zu tun
mit eigentlich mit die lust zu
verschwinden
die lebenberg wurde ich sich das auch
anhören
erklären sie mal wenn man so etwas würde
dann verschwindet man auch dann ist man
nicht mehr alleine aber man ist auch
nicht mehr derjenige der mann ist sind
das ist eigentlich symbiotische lebe und
menschen die die neigung habe in eine
symbiotische liebe sich zu verlieren
verlieren sich auch in das ist das
machen sich interessant für mich war
eigentlich das ideal der erwachsenen
liebe immer eher dasjenige das man raum
zwischen den liebenden lässt dieses
gefühl von nahe kommen und trotzdem
einander ja auch freien raum lassen den
sie ja zum beispiel auch eben zu
schreiben brauchen auch das zusammen
ja das ist merkwürdig aber das geht
zusammen
denn ich denke dass jeder der sich sehen
eigenes image liebe versteht auch sehr
gut was einsamkeit ist weil man zur
trend ist weil man sich sehr bewusst ist
von dieser einsamkeit und die auch wenn
man erwachsen wird als ein schicksal
empfindet dass man anfängt zu leben denn
man braucht die einsamkeit um
schriftsteller zu sein und es geht geht
sehr gut zusammen mit menschen die sich
so leben dass sie sehr gut verstehen
dass der andere auch einsam
ist und raum braucht und ob frei ist und
wenn ihr noch kurz sprechen über diesen
mythos der ist ja wirklich die idee es
gibt diese eine hälfte die man suchen
muss
sie haben mehrere leben gelebt also auch
die scham aber nicht ihre erste liebe
die sie irgendwo die achte liebe das war
alles nur liebhaber los
ich habe nie ein mann es war wirklich
der erste mann wovon ich dachte das ist
liegen da steht mein mann nicht da steht
noch mal ein liebhaber oder wie sagt man
auf deutsch an den armen ein liebhaber
das wird sie sagen als ob man märchen
lieb hat er ein liebhaber nein es war
klar das ist mein mann und das ist ganz
etwas anderes als ein liebhaber also so
ein moment der erkenntnis ja ja und gibt
es denn mehrere solche helfen die zu
einem passen können ja hört sich
merkwürdig an aber es ist natürlich nur
ein meter vor ihm metapher dies auch
dieses in einem körper zu sein ist alles
eine metapher für eine art sucht einen
verlangen eine art sich zu lieber eine
persönlichkeit und ja es gibt mehrere
hälfte die zu dir passen
sie haben hier ein stichwort gegeben
eine art sucht man spricht ja auch vom
liebesrausch oder und treten dann
spricht davon dass man trunken vor liebe
ist sucht und liebe passt dass sie sie
auch hin die zusammen diese ganz extreme
liebe indem man einfach schon rauschhaft
liebt er weil es mit sucht mit sehnsucht
zu tun hat mit
ich beschreibe in die freundschaft das
ist mein zweiter roman versuche ich
eigentlich die freundschaft auch zu
erklären durch sucht zu erklären und
dann mache ich ein unterschied zwischen
die sucht zu viel zu essen und die sucht
zu viel zu trinken
alkoholismus und eigentlich beschreibe
ich dann am ende sucht als ein
freundschaft ohne freund denn marlboro
er kann dich nie verlassen
also es auch keinen fall wieder diese
verlass uns angst die eine bestimmte
persönlichkeit und auch die
persönlichkeit die kleine kit aus meinem
buch prägt und freundschaft suchte seine
freundschaft ohne freund das ist dass
man eine art autonomie sucht also das
hat eben paradox man man sehnt sich so
nach dieses nach diesen zustand aber
eigentlich ist man eine art man ein viel
größeres bewusstsein von einsamkeit und
eigentlich auch eine sehr viel größere
sucht nach autonomie
das kann ich glaube ich jetzt hier gut
verstehen wenn ihr noch einmal bei
dieser parallele bleiben also sie
beschreiben im logbuch ja auch wie
schwierig sie auch finden einen guten
umgang zb mit alkohol zu finden also
durchaus auch diese schwierigkeit in
eine sucht vielleicht abzugleiten ein
suchtverhalten zu weise an den tag zu
legen
da könnte man sagen das ist ein problem
weil eben diese lehrstelle sicher nie
über decken lässt man hat diese
sehnsucht und sie lässt sich nicht
überdecken es ist der rausch der nur
vorübergehend dieses loch auffüllt aber
das loch bleibt aber bei dieser wahren
liebe die hier erlebt haben und uns
mehrere male erlebt haben und so
eingehend beschreiben
da es sich ja dann keine lehrstellen
mehr sondern sie haben ja dann diese
umarmung allein ich müsste doch die
liebe heilend wirken die liebe wirkt
auch das ist so und ich glaube auch dass
ich während meine liebe bei ihm weniger
dann dass alkoholismus ich bin ein
alkohol ist das weiß ich dass mich das
so beruhigt hat dass ich viel weniger
süchtig war es anders aber es wenn man
so süchtig ist wie ich
hat das auch eine körperliche seite und
da können die leben nichts dafür aber
noch körperlich süchtig sein nach liebe
oder das beschreiben sie auch jahres
beschreibt ja wer sie eigentlich alles
sucht wird erklärt aussucht schrecklich
es ist schrecklich sie ist vielleicht
auch ihre energie über ihre schubkraft
nein ist es nicht nur schrecklich sagt
man meine kraft ja und das ist
eigentlich von paradoxen geprägt ich
empfinde auch eine sehr grosse autonomie
die braucht man auch wenn man schreibt
die braucht man weil man und schreiben
so viel mut man so vermuten nötig hat um
sie um themen zu über themen
nachzudenken und über themen zu
schreiben
und man hat ein sehr großes gefühl für
das tabu aber als schriftsteller muss
man das tabu auch durchbrechen
man hat ein sehr großes gefühl für
geheimnisse aber als schriftsteller muss
man das geheimnis entdecken muss man das
keines enthüllen
man hat bindungsangst aber zu gleicher
zeit eine große von langer sich zu
binden
gut gutes leben ich durch wenn man so
viel die paradoxen versteht und nicht
böse wird das s bahn paradoxen gibt ist
es ein gutes leben und ich denke auch zb
das suchte oder diese das trug tivi tät
die mit sucht verbunden in das sie
eigentlich zu tun hat mit einem
übergroßen lebenslust
genau das habe ich ja vorhin gemein mit
der schubkraft hat jasmin gerat noch was
anderes gesagt was ich so interessant
fand sie haben gesagt wenn man das
akzeptiert dass es diese abgründe gibt
dieser schwierigkeiten gibt dann ist es
ein gutes
ist das gute leben wie sie ein
verwöhntes leben versöhnt weiß ich nicht
ich finde ein gutes leben ein leben wo
man eigentlich täglich versucht mehr zu
verstehen zu geben dass es nicht
unaufmerksam vorbei geht aber mit eine
gewisse konzentration zu geben da sprich
die philosophin sie haben ja selber
philosophie studiert da fällt einem
natürlich dann sofort sokrates ein mit
seiner idee das gute leben ist das
geprüfte leben ist das durchdachte leben
ein leben aus gründen auch wie ein stück
weit sind ist auch die beiden pole die
ihr leben beherrschen das denken und
schreiben auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite diese unglaubliche
lust am leben dieses rauschhafte das
sehnsüchtige ja dass das haben sie gut
gesagt danke nein es gehört ja ich kann
mich sehr gut ich kann sehr gut allein
sein und dann denken nachdenken lesen
schreiben und ich sehe mich auch noch
dieses andere leben mit jetzt mit
freunde aber natürlich mit mit zwei
männer das war ein wunderbares dem für
mich und auch meine jugend schon diese
große freundschaft ich hatte als junges
mädchen und die auch 30 jahren von
meinem leben bestimmt hat das war auch
schon ziemlich symbiotisch tja sie sagen
das war ein gutes leben ist es in dieser
art und weise vorbei ich bin schon immer
ein gutes leben aber ich sage immer ich
hab euch noch zwei dinge in diesem leben
gesehen dass es dieses dieses werk
schreiben und groß eine große liebe
und jetzt habe ich noch das schreiben
und main die große liebe das sind diese
gute tiefe und ob sehr intime
freundschaften geworden denn nochmals
eine große liebe danach sehe ich es mich
eigentlich nicht mehr
das war genug
wissen sie was mir fehlt wenn ich ihnen
zuhöre etwas ein nämlich das vorwort der
großartigen autobiografie von virgin
russell den britischen philosophen ok in
diesem nun das schöne vorwort schreibt
er ist heute 13 10 seinem leben gegeben
die ihn immer angetrieben hätte
einerseits die sehnsucht danach zu
verstehen und zu wissen
die sehnsucht nach der liebe und die
sehnsucht danach mit menschlich zu sein
und den menschen zu helfen
oh ja leider das habe ich nicht das
wollte ich sie gerade frieden habe ich
ihn nicht haben ja sehr sehr viele
freunde aber es interessiert mich als
habe mich jetzt gerade an deutschland
treffen
das gibt gibt es diese dritte energie
für sie auch noch dieses gefühl für
andere da sein zu wollen oder sicher
fast zerreißen zu lassen davon zu sehen
wie schlecht es anderen menschen auch
gehen kann jetzt gerade angesichts
dieser welt nagelt nein ich bin ziemlich
aber nicht so politik und ich habe immer
doch ich kann eigentlich nur menschen
helfen mit meine bücher
ich hoffe immer dass meine bücher
menschen mit ihrer einsamkeit versöhnen
und zu gleicher zeit zeigen dass es noch
andere gibt die auch so leben auch so
denken wie sie also ich habe es immer
meine bücher immer gesehen als meiner
heirat mit die welten um sie zu
schreiben muss ich mich aus die welt
zurückziehen und ich ertrage nicht ich
ertrage menschen einfach nicht sehr
lange
das kann ich machen was in einem
menschen auch einfach fremd aber wenn
wir noch einmal über diese urgewalt
sprechen zurückkommen zu ihrer metapher
dieses wort der urgewalt der liebe
das kommt vor unter anderen in diesen
neuen buch du sagst es ihr neuester
roman in dem sie diese irrsinnige
liebesgeschichte erzählen zwischen
schillerplatz und der user einen
autorenpaar ein intellektuelles paar das
sich in den 1950 er jahre findet in
opfert sich verliebt
unglaubliches entschuldigung cambridge
unglaubliches schafft beide zwei dichter
aber eigentlich leider diese liebe immer
darunter dass sie ja platz eine
depressive persönlichkeit ist eine
person die auch unglaublich narzisstisch
veranlagt ist und schlussendlich nimmt
sie sich das leben ja glauben sie diese
lieber wenn wir sie auch über gewalt
beschreiben kann auch ein abgrund sein
und leute zerstören
ja das kann
das sieht man auch ich weiß nicht ob
wenn du sagst es oder in auch in der
wirklichkeit von service deuce
ob es die liebe war die sie zerstört hat
ich denke dass serverplatz nation am 24
einen sehr ernsten selbstmordversuch
getan und der was war war fast gelungen
und ich glaube sie war ja ich glaube sie
konnte nicht weiterleben ohne ihn aber
sind da es hat auch etwas zu tun mit
ihrer mit ihrem ja persönlichkeit wider
und mit einer fantasie eigentlich über
das opfer wenig sind so versuche ich sie
zu verstehen dass sie eigentlich gedacht
hat ich werde belohnt wenn ich
verschwinde
fast wie und es ist auch was ein opfer
war wie jesus christus ich werde mich
opfern damit etwas gutes passiert
das ist eine fantasie ist eigentlich
eine megalomane fantasie zu gleicher
zeit zeigt es auch ich meine der jurist
beschreibt ihn als an fanatiker seine
religiöse eiferer und das versuche ich
ihn du sagst es klar zu machen dass sie
diese vorstellung dieser ideen hatte
wenn ich mich opfer ist das gut wenn ich
verschwinde ist das gut
hat das etwas heiliges und eigentlich
ist das wahnsinnige dass es noch stimmt
auch ich es ist fast keine
schriftstellerin nie so berühmt geworden
ist und auch so einig geworden ist für
andere frauen als etwas was ja auch
auffällt ist dass diese figur oder die
die areale schrift stellen sie in japan
hat sehr autobiografisch geschrieben sie
hat so sehr autobiografisch geschrieben
dass verschiedene personen auf versucht
haben und die publikation zu verhindern
auch posthum ihre mutter habe auch
briefe herausgegeben diese was er
geschrieben hat um das bild
zurechtzurücken der braven tochter
sozusagen also das war unangenehm was
sie geschrieben hat und in dieser
offenherzigkeit in der sie ihre eigene
geschichte erzählt hat hat sie mich kurz
aber auch an sie erinnert weiß ich auch
sehr autobiografisch zum teil schreiben
zumindest zwei bücher haben sie ihren
lesern und leserinnen geschenkt die sehr
sehr autobiografisch sicher fühlen sie
sich ein stück weit mit sie in japan
auch verwarnt natürlich auch ja verstehe
sie zu ein gewisse grenze es ist mir
auch fremde als hysterikerin als manisch
depressiv als manipulativ das ist
hoffentlich alles was ich nicht bin aber
das autobiografische das verstehe ich
sehr gut natürlich und auch ihre kraft
versteht und es war auch sehr lieb und
auch sehr witzig und auch sehr brav
gegenüber ihre mutter und frau und er
eigentlich ist das auch pure ironie dass
ich die juso über das autobiografisch
schreiben lassen das ist genau das was
ich fragen war da sowohl sich leicht
dieser cook dieser als in japan ein
stückweit nahe sind wir wählen sie die
perspektive und tattoos lassen sozusagen
ihm zu wort kommen er erzählte
geschichte
da erzählte geschichte in ein langer
monolog aber er liebt sie so dass alles
was er tut ist versuchen sie besser zu
verstehen und die ehe besser zu
verstehen die liebe besser zu verstehen
und am letzten endes vielleicht auch ist
es lag auch ein langes großes versuch
ihre selbstmord zu verstehen
und das gelingt ihm nicht es er versucht
er gibt vielleicht zehn antworten ob die
frage warum bin ich schuld bin ich
schuld daran dass meine frau selbstmord
begangen hat ist die welt schuld daran
ist die kinder fühlen sich schuldig aber
sind kinder
also er hat sehr viele fragen und
eigentlich auch sehr viele antworten
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass die
persönlichkeit sehr stark dafür
verantwortlich ist wie wir lieben kann
mir dann sagen es gibt auch gar nie
schuldige in einer liebe sondern jeder
kriegt die liebe und legt die liebe die
er sozusagen anzieht durch sein eigenes
ließen
ja ich finde dass in die liebe den
schuldigen gibt und sich sicherlich
nicht wenn eine liebe endet durch ein
selbstmord ich meine der anna fühlt sich
schuldig das ist das ist unerträglich
aber dass das ist wahr aber wenn es die
absicht ist von einer frau oder ein mann
wenn es die absicht ist denn andere zu
strafen dann finde ich selbstmord so
unethisch dann bin ich jetzt eigentlich
den schrecklichsten tat der mann in
einem leben tun kann
also ich muß und habe auch versucht er
geplant so zu verstehen dass man mit ihr
zu tun hat dass man
empathie hat für wie schwierig das leben
fürs für sie war
wie schwierig sie es auch fand der
perfektionismus die beste mutter zu sein
die beste in diesem punkt leichter ab
von ihnen sie hat kinder und findet ihr
auch sehr sehr schwierig diese rollen
und gerhus kombinieren wir aber
gleichzeitig gibt es ja doch diesen
moment der schuldfrage im buch nämlich
insofern dass sie ein stück weit auch
ted hughes die möglichkeit geben gegen
sagen wir mal die vereinnahmen
feministinnen die silja platz zur
heiligen jakobus haben zur ikone die
gescheitert ist an diesen an dieser
schwierigkeit eben nutzer sein zu müssen
und dichterin sein zu wollen ein stück
weit haben sie versucht tadeusz die
möglichkeit zu geben sich zu
rehabilitieren weil er war eigentlich
klar sündenbock für viele ein stück weit
auch eine rechnung offen mit den
feministinnen nein die feministen sind
ganz gut
es sind wenn sie streiten für gleiche
rechte
aber was sie mit tattoos getan haben das
war nicht so gut
das waren nicht nur die vier minister
war auch die biografen aber die
feministen und das ist ein ziemlich
aggressive also die zweite welle filmen
ist es war ein ziemlich aggressive welle
und sie haben zum beispiel das
beschreibe ich auch in meinem roman
jedes mal das grab von sylvia plath
vernichtet durch den namen von news den
namen news abzuhacken von vom stein das
ist natürlich so aggressiv aber das war
auch der umgang mit ihm als ehemann man
hat ihn sehr aggressiv begegnet und wenn
er in amerika zum beispiel lesungen
hatte dann gab es immer frauen die mir
ein großes tuch förderer da ins publikum
standen unterschrieben und er hat dann
auch keine lesungen mehr gemacht in
amerika war das so schmerzt natürlich
aber man hat ein sündenbock gesucht und
so soll einer der leading lady von diese
zweite welle hat auch gesagt so wie sie
war für uns eine heilig und wir haben
und sei ein sündenbock gesucht und da
wartet und das ist natürlich etwas in
der geschichte das so unehrlich ist und
unrecht und ja ich habe versucht das bis
hin zu jain zu rehabilitieren
wenn wir noch einmal zurückkommen zur
idee der urgewalt dann kann ja sagen es
gibt eine andere urgewalt ist natürlich
die liebe die man als nur gebaut
bezahlen kann aber es gibt eine andere
urgewalt die sie selber hautnah erlebt
haben nicht der tod das ist vielleicht
noch die gewalttätige hre gewalt in
unserem leben weil wir sie nicht wählen
können wir können sie nicht ablehnen wir
können sie nicht uns auswählen sie kommt
über uns ja der tod ist ist eigentlich
immer da
er war für mich immer da ich war als
kind schon sehr beschäftigt mit dem tod
aber nochmals ich habe später auch
verstanden also eine sehr große
lebenslust die mich dazu zwang
vielleicht so viel an den tod zu denken
und augen den tod von meinen liebsten
von meinem vater und mutter meine brüder
und später von meine zwei männer
ich denke ich nur sagen dass das tod
verursacht treue und das reue trauer
eine extreme form des leidens ist ich
finde dass noch immer unterschätzt wird
zu gleicher zeit zwingt die liebe man
hört ja nicht auf ein anderer zuliebe
wenn er stirbt man bleibt verliebt man
bleibt den anderen lieben und das sorgt
dafür dass nicht mehrere frauen und
männer selbstmord begehen
weil aus trauer ich denke dass es trauer
sehr viel mit depression zu tun hat dass
es das leiden von depression ähnlich
sieht aber weil man noch so liebt ist
führt es auch dass diese trauer ein
geschenk ist für den toten geliebten das
heißt der selbst nur das mit sieht wäre
sozusagen eine negation dieser liebe die
weiter fortbesteht und die man auch
immer noch für sich haben möchte wir ja
die man auch schenken möchte die muss
raus die muss liebe ist ja so eine kraft
die muss raus
die muss zum anderen und man kann sehr
lange noch liebe fühle für einen toten
geliebten die liebe muss raus deshalb
muss man weiterleben muss man trauern
und weiterleben und nach einem zwei drei
jahren wird das alles etwas sanfter und
wird auch die liebe ruhiger denn anfangs
ist immer noch sehr physisch und
körperlich und stark und dieses
ungleiche paar eros und thanatos die
liebe und der tod da sind ja wirklich
zweiten man kann sagen urgewalt in
unserem leben beginnen die sich auch so
gegenseitig was man sagen könnte wir
könnten gar nicht lieben wenn wir nicht
sterblich werden
oder anders gesagt könnten wir
gleichermaßen liegen wenn wir wissen wir
sterben nie sind unsterblich gehirn
gegen die zusammenlegung soll sich
zusammen und ich gehe von dem moment an
dass man anfängt zu leben fängt man auch
an an den tod zu denken ich ganz am
besten früher mit das was ich nicht habe
nämlich kinder
ich bin mir sehr sicher mit wenn man ein
kind hat dann kreiert man nicht nur ein
kind aber auch einen tot und ich bin mir
sicher dass die liebe die man für ein
kind spürt dass sie auch immer durch
todesangst bestimmtes auch so stark ist
weil man sich so fürchtet
das etwas mit diesem kind passiert sie
mit man kreiert einen tut wenn man ein
kind bekommt dann bekommt man auch einen
tod das kind wird nämlich sterben nicht
gleich licht dass man das ist er lebt
und dass klein lisa bauer der das hofft
man aber auch sehr oft passiert dass
auch wir leider ist eine sehr große
tragödie
aber kinder manche kinder gehen auch tot
vor dass man aber sie gehen tod und wenn
man selbst als sie voran geht
man muss sich das realisieren etwas sagt
ihr als mutter als vater ich habe auch
ein tod kreieren es ist ja auch so schon
freude hat das immer betont es gibt
eigentlich nichts was uns ungeschützter
macht auf die liebe ja ganz am anfang
unseres gesprächs eine darüber
gesprochen die große sehnsucht ist jedem
wo schutz zu finden und sich zu zweit
symbiotisch durchs leben zu wälzen damit
man ja nicht irgendwie zerbricht auch am
leben aber eigentlich macht einen die
liebe auch extrem schutzlos oder
ungeschützter walde von unstrut
das ist wahr das hab ich es auch bin ich
und werde die engsten größe und ja man
wird verletzlich aber das ist auch es
ist auch gut und herrlich unverletzlich
zu sein man für mehr man denkt besser
man ja man genießt mehr vom leben
sie hätten nicht gerne eine härtere hand
eine dickere haut
nein ich weiß natürlich nicht so gut wie
es wie man wie sich dann fühlt aber nein
ich glaube nicht
ich glaube dass ich dann kein
schriftsteller wäre und das schreiben
ist mir alles sie haben darüber haben ja
eigentlich schon gesprochen zwei mal
einen geliebten mann verloren und das
beschreiben sie hemmungslos schonungslos
auch was passiert wenn man so
unglaublich traurig aber auch ganz
konkret wie sie mit diesen toten
körpern auch umgehen ich erlaube mir
jetzt mal in dieses erlauben in der
gleichen art und weise schonungslos sie
zu fragen weil ich das unglaublich
angerührt habe wie fühlt sich das an
wenn man sich nackt auf einen leichten
anlegt weil das beschreiben sie in
diesem buch und das geht einem ungeheuer
nein
ja ja das ist glaub nicht sich nackt war
aber es muss ich mann mann mann mann
muss sich verabschieden von so einen
körper und der ist kalt und man wird
selbst sehr kalt und es ist traurig man
ist sehr traurig war sehr traurig aber
es muss ich musste immer zurück zu
diesem körpers hatte so etwas etwas
tierisches das verlangen das und auch
weil man es nicht glauben kann man muss
sich auch gewöhnen an den tod so eines
gelebten körpers und ich bin auch froh
dass wir nicht einen menschen so schnell
begraben zb in israel wo das glaube dass
oder die wärme eines landes einen dazu
zwingt sehr schnell cia innerhalb 24
stunden einen menschen zu begraben denn
man braucht es man braucht es diesen
körper zusehen und sich zu verabschieden
sie haben vom verlangen gesprochen ist
es das verlangen wirklich noch einmal
diesen körper zu spüren dass das
verlangen die sehnsucht die liebe die
immer noch da ist ja oder ist es das
verlangen sicher zu sein dass die person
wirklich tot ist in diesen mann ist
gleich klar das ist gleich klar wenn
eine tot ist das weiß man innerhalb
einer minute
tod ist so tot das ist so absolut und so
klar nein es hat alles tun mit abschied
abschied abschied von einem körperlich
man sich realisiert dass man das nun
noch
frage noch bei sich hat und so nah an
sich auch wenn es kalt ist
nicht alle menschen können das so wie
sie es gibt menschen die können sich vor
toten körpern ich glaube sogar dass bei
den allermeisten menschen so ich sehe
das hab ich gehört von anderen und das
hat mich sehr verwundert
wir frauen dort können sie gar nicht
verstehen das kann ich nicht verstehen
und haben sie gegenüber gar keinen toten
menschen so sagen wir mal distanz oder
sogar ekelgefühle sie haben ja vorher
von sehr sehr vielen menschen abschied
nehmen müssen das beschreiben sie eben
auch in diesem blog buch das in der
geringen da sind kinder des verstorbenen
mannes ganz ganz viele personen nein
dass das was ich mit
meine männer getan haben also die das
bedürfnis diesen körper ganz an mich zu
drücken oder auf sie zu legen
das habe ich nur mit meinem männer getan
für für andere gestorbene war eine viel
größere distanz und habe ich mich sehr
sehr benommen und habe auch nicht das
bedürfnis gespürt mich sehr nah an
diesem körper ranzugehen
im gegenteil kurz gucken und dann weg
gehen es ist ich finde dass körper
gehört mich auch nicht dass körper von
den anderen von harry mulisch zb oder
für eine niederländische auto oder von
die älteste tochter von hans die auch
starb sie haben in dieser zeit ein lied
so oft gehört nämlich danny boyle eine
irische balladen gehören ein paar takte
rein
[Musik]
lisa
1 no
in orange
[Musik]
er kommt zurück
aber die person die sinkt ist dann schon
tot aber hat den eindruck es geht
trotzdem um ein sich wieder sehen ist
dass das was sie fasziniert von diesem
lied gibt es nun ist ein gar nicht denn
wir werden uns nicht wieder sehen nein
ich glaube ich schreib da ich nehm ich
bin mir sicher ich glaube es ist kurz
vor lok woher das war das lieblingslied
von hans und ich rede noch dass wir das
zum ersten mal hörte wenn wir zusammen
in washington waren und wir liefen dort
auf gibt es in ein erinnerungsort genau
das ist ja alles geschah unter hörten
wir plötzlich danny boyle und dran sie
trainiert hat er geweint und und wenn
ein krankenhaus in seiner letzten sechs
wochen die beschreibung buch hat er
gesagt du weißt doch welches lied ich
hören möchte auf meine beerdigung und
abgesagt und das war danny boyle und ich
habe deine blieb ich liebe all diese
irische balladen und es hat mich auch
wieder
näher zu tattoos gebracht der immer
englische und irische beladen gesungen
hat er dann sehr gut stimme und mit
freunden und familie bleibt also immer
gesungen und vielleicht auch danny boyle
aber das weiß ich nicht ich hab das
nirgendwo zurückgefunden you can use
verbindet sie ja tatsächlich auch dass
auch er zweimal geliebte frauen in
diesem fall verloren hat allerdings
haben sich diese beiden frauen beide
eben umgebracht und sie haben ja am
anfang gesagt dass ich natürlich was
anderes wenn man suizid begeht dann
intern ist man so was wie eine
schuldfrage
das ist nicht der fall wenn sozusagen
der natürliche tod der tragische tod der
über einen konnten form einer krankheit
ließ bei ihren männern java und re
situation trotzdem gibt es vielleicht
diese parallele auch zwischen ihnen
nein das hat mich eigentlich nicht so
gut realisiert ich habe den tod von die
zweite frau mit denen er sind wir
eigentlich betrogen hat ja ich denke
dass es so klar war für heißen dass es
so klar war dass der ewz eigentlich nur
eine große liebe hatte und das wasser
bleibt dass sie nicht dass sie das als
eine rivalin empfunden hat und sie hat
auch exakt diesen selbstmord von serbien
bleibt kopiert aber hat leider auch die
vierjährige tochter von der jus und sie
mit in diesen tod genommen haben sich
verkauft sie haben alle vergast
das war damals übrigens eine ganz
gewöhnliche art sich selbst umzubringen
denn es gab noch gas oben und es war ein
sanfter tod geschrieben also samstag
aber das war in dieser zeit der
gewöhnlichste art sich wenn es das
vertrauen es war ein typischer ja die
nach china die kennen ja wir sind ja wie
ein gasofen wirkt ein bisschen makaber
schuldige
wenn wir trotzdem bei diesem moment
bleiben zwei mal eine person zu
verlieren wie es eben bei tattoos der
fall war und bei ihnen der fall ist
stellt sich ja schon ein stück weit auch
die frage lernt man eigentlich vom einen
tod für den anderen tot und sie
schreiben im logbuch dass sie diese
frage auch ärgert dass dies schwierig
finden dass man zum teil auch sagst hast
du doch schon einmal durchgestanden und
dass sie gefunden haben dass ich wieder
ganz neu weil diesen hans van mierlo
haben ja nicht schon mal ein anderer
mann ja ist es üblich so dass man gar
nichts mitnimmt dann erfahrung nach
einem hilft
nein nein nein es hilft nichts
und auch hier muss ich den vergleich
machen mit menschen die gefährlich sind
vor depressionen auch die und ob die
kehren zurück die depressionen auch hier
menschen die sich so die leider durch
gequält werden durch diese krankheit
denken auch immer auch wenn es das das
erste mal gelungen ist aus dieser
depression heraus zu kommen wenn es zum
zweiten mal denkt sie ist
ich komme nie ausgeht dass ich werde nie
aus dieser depression kommen und das
dritte mal denken sie auch wieder das
zweite mal kommen sie auch wieder raus
das dritte mann denken sie jetzt wird
das nicht mehr klappen deshalb begehen
so viele menschen mit depressionen
selbstmord und mit roher je mit trauer
ist das das gleiche man denkt ich habe
gar nichts gelernt ich habe ich weiß
nicht wie ich mich dieses extremen
leiden entgegensetzen muss ich weiß nur
eins und das habe ich auch beschrieben
dass der körper nur ein bestimmtes maß
von leiden erträgt von psychischen
leiden und dass man dann irgendwo ein
thermostat ort der sagt und jetzt mal
kurz nicht dass man dann auch sehr kurz
nicht leidet sowie kleine trauer pausen
ja
ja und ich weiß natürlich intellektuell
dass es ein jahr dauert das man alles
zum ersten mal alleine tun muss ist ja
eigentlich jeden tag jeden tag ist jeden
tag ist er ist das erste mal ein tag
ohne ihn und das zweite jahr macht man
das schon zum zweiten mal hat man zum
zweiten mal den ersten jahren war ohne
ihn und den zweiten und den dritten und
dann hat man schon ein bisschen geübt
das dritte jahr ist man noch ein großer
erfahrung hat man noch mehr erfahrung
und so peters weiter
trotzdem sind sie natürlich für viele
leute sie aus doppelte witwe ein stück
weit auch ein vorbild zu sagen guck mal
die hat was auch überlebt ja so gehen
wie vielleicht auch mitleiden um das wir
schauen andere haben es auch überlegten
ihr habt vielleicht doch etwas tod
spenden des zumindest ich hoffe es durch
ein vorbild bin für die menschen das
sonderbar sind sie so reden die
sehnsucht von virgin russell haben sie
trotzdem okay wer interesse hat gerne
menschen geholfen und ja ich mache das
nur gute freunde und familie und
wahrscheinlich machen sich mit ihren
büchern noch für mehr mal den büchern
aber lassen sie uns noch noch über ein
anderes thema sprechen kann mich
beschäftigt manchmal dass ich denke so
wie sie dieses leben und lieben und
leiden diese sehnsucht beschreiben denke
ich manchmal sind hier eigentlich heute
in einer zeit angelangt so was gar nicht
mehr so richtig platz hat wie sind doch
heute so personen geworden die sich
selbst tracken die sich optimieren die
via partner vermittlungsagenturen die
möglichst gut passende liebe möglichst
effizient suchen alles muss sich rechnen
alle anstrengungen müssten sich rechnen
sind wir heute überhaupt noch bereit für
die ganz großen gefühle
ja ich denke es das ja ich weiss nicht
im großen ganzen oder ob man sprechen
kann für alle
ich denke dass es sowieso schon ziemlich
eine ausnahme ist wenn man sich so sehen
aber eine große liebe ob sie es
nooteboom hat mal sehr schön
geschriebene ich glaube in marseille
eine große liebe fängt an mit noch eine
große sich noch eine große liebe zu
sehen
und ich glaube es wird immer menschen
geben die wie ich die die sich seelen
noch so ein symbiotisch leben die so
eine persönlichkeit haben als sie würden
sie nicht so dass unsere zeit sich
gewandelt hat und es war immer so es gab
immer menschen die haben sich nach
dieser liebe gesehen und immer menschen
die haben sich dann auch nicht gesehen
oder hatten gleich den mut nicht ja oder
sind ganz andere ich bin ein plateau
beschreibt es schon es ist ein alter
text und platte beschreibt dann auch
alle anderen arten von liebe er die
liebe von einer von männer die gerne
junge jungs etwas lernen
die freundschaft liebe die ich das liebe
die ich glaube es gibt sehr viele arten
von leben so wie es auch sehr viele
unterschiedene persönlichkeiten gibt und
und sehr unterschiedene sehnsüchte
vielleicht ist der erfolg ihrer bücher
gerade auch daran festzumachen dass sich
so viele menschen danach sehnen eine
solche liebe zu finden
aber eigentlich den mut nicht haben sie
wirklich in ihr leben rhein zulassen
oder nicht die zeit die kosten nämlich
sehen dass ich das was ich meinte
herzlich da nicht etwas verändert denke
ich noch immer menschen so wie ich die
sehr viel zeit haben die sich leisten
können um den ganzen tag nachzudenken
und zu schreiben und die nicht die wir
in die welt hinaus müssen
und die haben auch genügend zeit für so
eine versengen liebe
und man muss sich natürlich auch sehen
nach eine art von der versenkung
nochmals eine art von verschwinden und
auch schriftsteller erkennen dass wenn
man ein buch schreibt verschwindet man
auch ein bisschen man denkt ein
schriftführer ist so mit sich selber
beschäftigt aber wenn man schreibt
verschwinden man auch ein bisschen
dieses moment glaube ich habe ich noch
nicht ganz verstanden ich glaube ich
verstehe ganz viel von dem was sie
erzählen aber dass mit dem verschwinden
dass wir dich gerne noch besser
verstehen weil man habe noch auch den
eindruck wenn man so richtig intensiv
liegt dann spürt man sich erst so
richtig dann verschwindet man doch nicht
ja das ist er es ist kein es ist ein
verlangen zu verschwinden
es ist eigentlich kennen zum beispiel
wenn man die lebens über lebens von
heiligen liest die möchte sehr gerne
verschwinden in die liebe für gott oder
die leben für den anderen menschen
sie meinen sie dass sie sich auflösen es
sich auflösen dass die grenzen
dort suchte hier ja es ist so es hat so
etwas ja ich würde fast sagen ordinäres
oder alltägliches dass man immer dabei
ist sich zu konservieren und eigentlich
ein schriftsteller ist derjenige der
gibt dr
ein konservatives schriftsteller gibt es
nicht
oder der streit schlechte bücher gibt es
natürlich auch die gibt es nämlich sehr
viele aber ein gutes konserve wird sich
nicht ergibt sich selbst weg dazu sei
noch eine eine andere figur aus der
philosophiegeschichte in den sinn
nämlich komme mit seinen mythos des
sisyphos soll man sagen könnte er hat ja
gesagt die absurdität die durchdringt
unser leben die
kriegen wir nicht raus das leben ist
absurd und sinnlos wenn wir nein wir
könnten das irgendwie verstehen oder
aushalten dann ihren tieren sondern
alles was wir können ist bis über die
grenzen hinaus trotzig unser leben
genussreich durchzuziehen da gibt es
natürlich den sieg wusste er den stein
rollt und nichts bereut der stein roth
wieder runter und er beginnt wieder von
vorne
aber es gibt eben auch in don't run der
liebt ohne rücksicht auf verluste der
sich richtig durchs leben durch liebt ja
ich darf nicht nur die ihnen im turnier
ja ich eigentlich beschreibe ich in ganz
der ehre ein don juan figur auch mit
alle seien sich auch überall ich ja aus
der mitte von dort wo aber etwas mehr
das ist etwas mehr als eine beschreibung
von sms durch ihn inspiriert aber es war
ein don toren aber dass der tourismus
ist eigentlich auch eine art krankheit
das ist auch ein ja ein leiden für einen
mann
man leidet auch an dass er nicht das
vermögen hat sich bei eine frau eine
frau zu lieben
er sehnt sich auch daran sehen sich auch
nach diesem körper der das aber kann es
nicht
er kann zumindest nicht bei einer person
bleiben aber an sich dieses wieder
vernünftige lieben und sehnen das wäre
ja nicht krank oder da würden sie sagen
das ist dann gehe das aber dass sie
kraft darum wer im leben bestimmt eine
kraft ja sie selber haben ja mal gesagt
diese beiden lieben die waren so groß so
auf zehn stück weit auch sie möchten
sich eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr
verlieren ja insoweit dass ein
entschluss sein kann und
man die kräfte der natur widerstehen
kann würde ich gerne nicht mehr eine
große liebe haben
ich sehe mich nicht mehr und wenn es
stimmt was sie es not um seine große
liebe fängt an mit sich noch eine große
liebe zu sehen
dann habe ich die sehnsucht nicht mehr
ich bin sehr zufrieden und ich hab ich
bin auch sehr ruhig geworden und ich
lebe in das haus meines mannes und spüre
ihnen noch so und die seine anwesenheit
ist noch immer sehr groß für mich und
ich genieße das aber ich genieße auch
das alleinsein und wie wir katholiken
sagen ich lebe in das reich der lebende
unter diesen toten
dann lebe ich auch mit diesen toten
haben sie sehr schön gesagt ich glaube
dass fast wie so ein bisschen zusammen
über die vielen dinge die wir gesprochen
haben man kann diese urgewalt nicht
außen vor lassen aber man kann also
aufhören sozusagen die sehnsucht nach
dieser urgewalt einzuladen ins leben er
ja das hoffe ich dass ich mich das
entschieden und das die urgewalt nicht
so gewaltig ist als man manchmal denken
dass man auch sich sagen kann ja ich
möchte das nicht mehr
punkt und wenn doch wieder passiert
japan dann rufen sie nicht handeln dann
sprechen wir was bringt ihnen sehr für
dieses gespräch empfangen da geschehen
danke ja und wer sich eingehender mit
kaliforniens neuesten roman du sagst es
auseinandersetzen möchte dem empfehle
ich den nächsten literaturclub am ersten
oktober diskutiert meine kollegin
nicolas steiner mit ihrer kritiker hunde
die tragische liebesgeschichte
am nächsten samstag findet in zürich der
erste sei das land statt in dem sich
athleten mit einer behinderung
unterstützt von robotertechnik in
verschiedenen disziplinen messen
srf ist gleich mit dabei und die
sternstunde philosophie fragt am sonntag
ob das leben als cyborg ein besser
das leben ist zu gast ist der psychologe
berthold maier der seine linke hand
prothese weitaus praktischer findet als
einen natürlichen rechten arm jetzt
gleich geht es auch um die hände und
zwar um flinke hände der schweizer
musiker somalia beherrscht das
schlagzeugspiel wie wenige und erfindet
in new york seine ganz eigene klangwelt
die sternstunde musik gibt einen
einblick in sein schaffen und in seinem
leben
gute unterhaltung dabei und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]